did you know that the Dragon Ball Z
Bruce Faulkner score that you hear when
watching the show is not actually how it
originally sounded that's right when
Dragon Ball Z was printed in full for
the orange bricks they made quite a few
audio changes to update the show in
random spots throughout the series the
music for that Faulkner score was
altered and almost always for the worse
like take this scene for example Goku's
been that way ever since he was little
[Music]
it's like nothing ever got to him ah yes
Grim flashback music just what I needed
by comparison the original music for
that scene used this wonderfully
nostalgic wistful track Goku's been that
way ever since he was little
[Music]
it's like nothing
ever much to ask for Dragon Ball to not
be worse over time